when i was a kid obviously at mardi gras  everybody would show their and i  remember being young and it was  pre-internet and my uncle came and he's  from the styx of louisiana he'd never  been a mardi gras before he brought the  camera with the neck holder with the  lens and he was just and i remember his  wife was like stop it stop it god damn  it i i can't imagine he must have  developed those at home in his own dark  room one hour photo yeah yeah one hour  photo by the way can you can we talk  about that the the things those people  must have seen oh my god i had a rite  aid back in the day oh yeah oh there's a  whole seinfeld like a stanza oh that's  right that's right the art of seduction  yeah amazing favorites we all did a  pants  right back in the day you had to get a  pick developed that's true that was  everybody would take someone else's  camera and do like a shot with it or yes  and then just let them develop it oh  yeah you wait six months you're like  that'll pay off